you are very likely familiar with barry
weiss barry weiss is not a conservative
she used to work at the new york times
now she just has her own sub stack in
her own podcast and it's more credible
than anything you're seeing in the new
york times
but she's not a conservative sometimes
conservatives make this mistake where
whenever anyone questions the dominant
liberal regime in any way we just take
them in and we say you're one of us
you're one of us
but
she is not she's a liberal
who does not go along with the dominant
regime so
she was just on cnn she's still she's
liberal enough that she still gets
invited on cnn and she called out that
liberal ruling class for the
corruption and the coercion that it
it involves and she did this
specifically with brian stelter on the
ironically named show reliable sources
take a listen
you write there are tens of millions of
americans who aren't on the hard left or
the hard right who feel the world has
gone mad so in what ways has the world
gone mad
well you know when you have the chief
reporter on the beat of kovid for the
new york times talking about how
questioning or pursuing the question of
the lab leak is racist the world has
gone mad
when you're not able to say out loud and
in public that there are differences
between men and women the world has gone
mad you say we're not allowed we're not
able who's the people stopping the
conversation who are they
um people let work at networks frankly
like the one i'm speaking on right now
who try and claim that you know it was
it was racist to investigate the lab
league theory it was i mean you said
that
but i'm just saying that when you say
allowed i just think it's a provocative
thing you say you say you say we're not
allowed to talk about these things but
they're all over the internet i can
google them i can find them everywhere
i've heard about every story you
mentioned so i'm just suggesting of
course people are allowed to cover
whatever they want to cover
who's shutting down the conversation
who's who's not letting people spit hold
on shut up barry who's not letting keep
your mouth shut i'm not done talking
you're who's doing that you're not no
one's doing that okay i'll give you the
last word actually no i won't shut up
who's who's shutting down
uh you you are brian you are literally
shutting down the conversation right now
and
i i'm not sure that he really believes
what he's saying what he is saying is
that
the establishment media
do not in any way
suppress
questions about dr fauci questions about
the
covid origins and the associated public
health tyranny that they do not in any
way suppress
i don't know the distinction between men
and women and that's just preposterous i
could be kicked off of social media for
saying that men are not women and there
are specific rules around it which we
try to get around without compromising
the truth and the reality of what we're
reporting but we've been dinged on it
before on this show at the daily wire
elsewhere and then what is his argument
he says look
yeah maybe we don't cover any of these
things on cnn maybe we maybe the new
york times doesn't cover these things
but you can google it first of all
google will suppress the search results
but second of all is that that's really
your answer
virtually all the newspapers virtually
all the tv stations virtually all of the
main media outlets
also run by big tech which are going to
suppress certain stories like the hunter
biden laptop story or anything regarding
coved that doesn't go along with dr
fauci so yeah the all of the power
structures are going to suppress
those sorts of views but you know if you
poke around the deep recesses of the
internet maybe you'll find something so
it's the same it's not being said what
are you talking about dude
it's really frustrating barry weiss is
totally right here and brian stelter is
demonstrating how wrong he is i no
longer look at screens
if i'm gonna have to see that blue light
you're probably not even aware of it
because there's so much of it in our
culture and you see it on your phone and
you see it on the tv and you see it on
the computer screen well you can fix
that right now with blue blocks okay
blue blocks they're very cool
fashionable glasses and they will
seriously reduce your eye strain i mean
i was getting headaches from my eye
strain from and you didn't even know
what it is right but then the minute you
get rid of that blue light you're gonna
see it's it's the difference is really
really stark okay for some people that
blue light can even cause anxiety
depression low energy get rid of it now
with blue blocks they're evidence-backed
they're made under optics laboratory
conditions in australia they're they're
really really high-end right now head
over to blueblocks dot com slash knowles
use promo code knowles at checkout to
get 20 off and enjoy free shipping on
orders over 115 bucks get your energy
back sleep better block out the
unhealthy effects of blue light with
blue blocks that is b l u b l o x dot
com slash knowles or click the link and
uh make sure to use code knowles to get
20 off your order enjoy free shipping on
orders over a hundred fifteen bucks b l
u b l o x dot com slash knowles for
twenty percent off today you can thank
me later i think we need to go a little
further here
right
barry weiss is a good liberal i like her
i'm glad there are good liberals i'm
glad she's doing what she's doing she's
doing real work
we need to go further though
okay a lot of times this trap
conservatives fall into
is we pretend that good liberalism is
the goal that you know open relatively
open-minded liberals like barry weiss
those that's it that's the gold standard
and that's what we need to aim at and
the conservatives whine about
authoritarianism where they whine about
illiberalism where they do this both
sides kind of thing and that's just not
gonna cut it okay and this is why we
lose
because
those words don't really mean very much
okay authoritarianism or illiberalism go
read john locke okay john locke the
father of liberalism reads
as much more authoritarian or illiberal
or whatever slogan we want to use than
anybody who is being accused of those
things today
the the
the mealy-mouthed both sides let's just
kind of go back to five minutes ago
let's let's just preserve and conserve
the culture of
2013. that's not going to work we need
to actually have a view of what is true
and what is good and what is beautiful
and we we need to be willing to stand by
that i mean this is the point of my book
speechless controlling words controlling
minds which thanks to you all became a
number one national bestseller i think
it became a number one national
bestseller in part because it looked at
this thing and said no the answer is not
just to repeat the same old slogans
about
keeping an open mind and
having free speech absolutism and not
telling people what to think just how to
think and you know authoritarianism or
whatever it's
liberty entails limits and we need to be
willing to set those and stand by those
things and say look
if men and women to use barry's example
if men and women really are different
then that entails certain things and
that that means that you know men can't
go into the girls bathroom and it means
that men don't have a right to dress up
like women and pretend to be women and
it means that
actually marriage has a specific meaning
and it means that no maybe the
transportation secretary shouldn't take
two or three months of paternity leave
amid a transportation crisis and it just
implies certain things and it doesn't
just imply that we can do
x y and z it implies that we can't do
certain things as well it implies
limits i'm so glad you enjoyed that clip
i enjoyed it too you know i just felt it
sounded good it looked good i'm glad
that we can agree on that if you want to
see more clips if you want to see the
whole show subscribe here ring the bell
also head on over to apple podcast
spotify stitcher google play for free
you can subscribe to the michael knowles
show podcast helps us get around the
sensors that come up every now and again
we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you